just before I begin I want to take this
moment to acknowledge that the
conversation we're going to have is not
just a theoretical conversation this is
a real issue for many of us black people
and one that deeply impacts our lives
and our humanity and our dignity and as
we have this conversation I ask you all
to keep that in mind the civil rights
veteran Angela Davis has said recently
that in America this particular
historical conjuncture holds
possibilities for change that we have
never before experienced
she thinks this could be a watershed
moment for the u.s. could it be a
watershed moment for the UK intelligent
square has brought together an
incredible panel to discuss this tonight
with us we have david ola suga the
award-winning historian writer and
broadcaster and the author of black and
british a forgotten history is also the
presenter of the BBC TV series a house
through time I'm also delighted to
welcome dawn Butler the Labour MP for
Brent central and previously shadow
Secretary of State for Women and
equalities in jeremy corbyn's shadow
cabinet and also joining us from berlin
susan Niemann american moral philosopher
and author of learning from the Germans
confronting race and the memory of evil
and she explores how a country can come
to terms with its racist history she's
also the director of the Einstein forum
and formerly professor of philosophy at
Yale University and Tel Aviv University
so David I'm going to start with you
you're speaking to us from Bristol and
supported the protesters taking down
Edward Colston statue what at that
moment mean for the people of Bristol I
mean taking it down or adding a plaque
has been a conversation for years why
has it taken us so long well I think it
meant different things for different
people in Bristol I think there's two
Bristol's and for half the city it was a
incredible moment it was a moment in
which something that was an
embarrassment to the city something that
we were as ashamed to show visitors who
came to visit us that our city 425 years
had lauded and memorialized a
mass-murderer
but for many people in the city who I
think have wrongly convinced themselves
that Colston represents their history
and cared about people like then
then I think it's been a sort of
traumatic moment and the challenge now
is to find a way because something has
happened something decisive has happened
years of negotiation and petitions and
appeals things I've been involved in
that got nowhere well you think about
action is it's pretty decides if
something has happened we can't go back
to the world of this time last week the
challenge now is to have a discussion
and I think one of the I'm very pleased
to see personally Causton statue coming
down but I would have been much happier
to have seen it brought down through the
official channels but the question is
now is how do we you want to have a
bigger conversation the one Angela Davis
talked about in the quote that you just
mentioned how do we prevent the statues
conversation becoming dominant in that
statues a part of that but if we just
talk about statues and not this that
opportunities of this moment which is to
talk about race then I think we would
have been diverted and I think there's a
in the British press there's a comfort
of talking about statues and I've been
asked to be taking a lots of debates and
it's like people have got the PlayBook
out from 2080 in the last time this
issue blew up but things have changed
it's not 20 18 30 big things are
happening bigger ideas bigger
discussions we Muslim let them drag us
back away from this moment to a familiar
debate of 2018 and I think that's a very
important point David although we will
be talking about statues just for a
little bit the more pertinent part of
this conversation is is what it says
about as you say race in history and
before I continue I just want to say we
have oh we have about 1,500 people in
the audience so thank you all who have
joined us from across the world and
please do ask questions if you have
Susan I want to come to you what see
what do you think removing statues says
I am it yes what happened to the Nazi
Snatchers in Germany is it about erasing
history or is it about something else
before I answer that question and let me
just say that I'm always puzzled by the
claim that status' our history we don't
memorialize every piece of history we've
memorialized things that we want to
value and that we want our children to
walk by and saying
this person embodied the values that I
care about so you know if statutes are
about values they're not about history
and and I add when you said you asked
mean people should remember this is a
real issue for black people there are an
awful lot of white people for who this
is a real issue too
and it's a different kind of issue I
don't want to deny that but I don't see
it as a question of black history
opposed to white history but of truth
rather than lies and justice rather than
injustice and you know that's why I and
my kids have been you know and but many
many other people you see them across
the world have been engaged in this
moment as soon as the question about an
athlete statues so they were forbidden
by the Allies there are a couple left in
but they're in very out-of-the-way
places I actually thought that there
were none but you know people corrected
me but they're you know in little towns
where nobody took them down well what
you have instead is an incredible number
of statues and memorials to in different
ways to the victims of Nazi terror to
people who were in the resistance I mean
my my favorite example which I think has
gone into different countries than it
could be even broader are these things
called stumbling stones they're about
that large and they're brass plaques
they're put in front of buildings which
were the last known address of people
who were murdered by the Nazis because I
saw David had his hand up and then we're
gonna come to dawn because I saw you
nodding as well David go ahead I was
actually scratching my nose but I'm
quite happy what's interesting about
what Susan says is I recognize that
entirely and I'm mentally impressed by
Germany's capacity to do that but when
it comes to memory
of the German colonial empire I think
you have a situation much more like the
situation we have in Britain the
Germany's willingness to confront this
in its memorial landscape
it begins in 1933 and ends in 1945 the
crimes committed by the the age of the
kaisers in the maybe reign in what's now
Tanzania those monuments are still up
there are monuments to generals
administrated ministered concentration
camps there are monuments to the first
world war in Africa there are monuments
to two men who were responsible for
I mean Germany's first genocide in
namibia now those statues are still up
so it is selective no it's let me say
this just to try and capsulate it it
took Germany a very long time to come to
the point where it stopped thinking of
itself as the worst victim of the war
and began to take some responsibility
for it you know people tend to think oh
my god the German crimes were so
horrible they must have gotten on their
knees the minute the war was over and
begged for atonement they resisted it
very very strongly especially in West
Germany but we are having that debate
about colonialism right now in this
country it's a big debate and you know
it's kind of one step at a time I think
I'm not suggesting people go slow in
Nina Simone's words but I am suggesting
that we acknowledge to move from
thinking of yourself as a hero to
thinking of yourself as a victim to
thinking of yourself as a perpetrator is
something that actually nobody wants to
do and it's hard what do you think do
you think that's partly why this is so
divisive in the UK I mean the Daily Mail
recently equated the pros and cons of
Colston equating the kind of slavery
with the pro of him helping to build the
West India Docks why why is this such an
emotive issue for people and why I folks
so desperate to find reasons to either
defend Colston or excuse libri well I
mean I don't think I would consider the
Daily Mail to be a good source of
information to be honest in anyone's
books but I think it is becoming quite
divisive and we cannot allow it to
become a black-and-white issue and I use
that term deliberately because it is
about history as Susan and David has
said and there's lots of people now that
are exploring that history and when I
was having this discussion with a
Conservative MP he almost tried to talk
about the pros and cons of Edward
Colston and I said but you've got your
own government has got a modern-day
anti-slavery bill so you are not in
favor of slavery so therefore you should
not be trying to argue any form of
slavery was right at that time because
it was never right and so we shouldn't
really get into that debate or that
argument and I thought and I think that
if we stick to the historical context of
everything if we then talk about how we
move forward who are the gatekeepers who
are making these decisions let's stick
to those factual things and then
everybody can embrace it as a truth
rather than one side or another and
that's where I think the debate needs to
go to we know that having watched the
the brutal lynching of George Bligh that
whatever came next was going to be
uncomfortable and so we have to just
appreciate that in a next step so where
we are will be uncomfortable for
everybody and we need to accept that
embrace it and then move forward and
don't I'm gonna build on that because
folks like Angela Davis have spoken of
this as a real moment some are saying
that this is a moment for the United
States the UK has had many opportunities
for a watershed moment from Stephen
Lawrence the uprisings in 2011 grenfell
Windrush even covert 19 what is this
moment any different I think the reason
why this moment feels different is
because the whole world was on lockdown
so we were actually focused on different
things our whole lives have been already
interrupted
Cobin 19 so all the new normalities of
going to work being in your car going
out for a drink for your friends you
know going out for dinner all of that
stopped and so we're all focused very
differently our lives changed and then
all of a sudden in front of our eyes we
watch the snow and brutal lynching of a
black man and by a white police officer
and it was very very difficult for
anybody to explain that away because
though normally when a racist incident
happens and there's always somebody in
the background explaining it well maybe
they had a knife or maybe they had a gun
well maybe there was no maybe because
when the camera then turned to the other
the other direction of of the killing
there was three other officers stood on
him so there was no other maybe so it
was very difficult to explain this
racism away and that's why I think this
moment is so different and the fact that
there's so many people taken to the
streets it's not just the black fight
when I was you know marching and you
know with my brothers it was just mainly
black people on the streets now it's
everybody all age groups all coming
together the people that rolled Coulsdon
down the road I don't think I saw a
black person road in him down the road
and I'm very grateful to people using
their white privilege to do that because
they probably won't get charged so you
know I don't think I saw a black person
rolling him down the road and I think
that's vital and important as a vision
to what we want society to be going
forward David do you think that real
change is possible without violence so
and I ask this because even peaceful
process even the peaceful process of
groups like the suffragists needed the
direction the direct action sorry of the
suffragettes for some women to get the
vote and so there are there are folks
that are pushing back against the
current movement saying direct action is
not the best way but should revolution
be by any means necessary
I think only if you're willing to go
through with it and what frightens me
sometimes about people on the Left
people
who I've agree with these people they
sit in academic conferences and talk
about revolution and don't think about
the consequences they're very often
people who do philosophy or literature
I've read history my whole life and it
makes me terrified I think the past is a
great you know in this country and this
is one of the problems we have statues
we see history is the sort of place you
give a recreation I with history books
and I'm terrified I have a child I worry
about the future and when I see people
on the Left talking about revolution I
think about the militias in America who
have the same agenda who have the same
language and they're in the fields of
m16s they're practicing and they're
preparing I think it's extremely
dangerous we are living in the midst of
a pandemic that may well be with us for
years we're in the middle of the biggest
recession since the Great Depression 40
million Americans are unemployed
we have a media that had failed us even
before this terrible moment of crisis we
have forms of communication and
manipulation with internet and social
media with the algorithms and their
manipulation that we have never known
before we still don't fully understand
their capacity to hollow out and
undermine democracies and civil civil
society the dangerous of that moment are
astonishing and profound and sobering so
I'm not gonna talk about about
revolution and I don't want to talk
about violence because I think if you
honestly look into that look into that
world think about what that would be
like it's it's a terrifying vision we
need to have conversations this is why I
say in Bristol the next thing and the
onus I think is on people like me who
were happy to see that statue toppled is
to try to explain to people why we felt
that way why the statue was put up who
Colston really was and tried to bring
round the people who feel that they have
been attacked by us attacking the 17th
century slave trader and tried to
convince them because the to talk about
revolution at this moment with the
fissures of history breaking apart I
is person I think it's a responsible
noting people are doing it need to go
and you know read more about the 20th
century and tell me you want a
revolution
I see Susan nodding yeah I'm not because
I share David's worries I am a
philosopher but I actually spend a lot
of time reading history and I also read
a lot of contemporary news about what's
going on in America and the worry is
that we've been talking about a cold
civil war since Trump came to office as
it turns into a hot one it's the right
that has the weapons so I am concerned
about this but I want to go back to
something that dawn said I really think
that the pandemic has put us in an
extraordinary moment and I it's not my
business to make prophecies I know
people there are people who want to go
this way or that way let me just remind
you that the Great Depression in the
twenties and thirties led in Germany to
the triumph of fascism but it led in the
u.s. to the closest thing to a social
democratic government we ever act so
it's in our hands it could go either way
and one of the things that's driving
people as you know people come out of
you mistreat them is it goes about the
world is the thing that things we
thought were entirely impossible before
the pandemic turned out to be possible
people who wanted us to fly less we're
being told oh yeah right sure they're
going to stop there easy jets and planes
are grounded you know I mean those the
good and bad things that we thought were
impossible suddenly happened we were
told there's no money for social
programs you know you left it so crazy
and suddenly they came up with trillions
of dollars you know like we trained
right yeah yeah so we're in a moment of
extraordinary possibility that might
just might produce real change without
the kind of violence that David is
rightly afraid of
dawn I'm gonna come to you on that
because I know I could see that you want
to add something and I'm also gonna add
an additional question to it which is
this movement is under the banner of
black lives matter but it's under the
banner of Bane which is black Asian
minority ethnic or people of color or
POC but because black people do suffer a
specific type of oppression and
intersection of oppressions but here in
the UK folks prefer to use Bane and PSC
and especially in government why do you
why do you think British people struggle
so much in naming and using the word
black or using or use the term Bheem are
they what's going on there and why I
never used that term and I think it's I
think it's a mistake to try and group
everybody together it means that if you
are looking at measuring and monitoring
it makes it very difficult to do that
but also you wouldn't really refer to
somebody
well I wouldn't as being vain so I would
never I don't ever use that term you'll
never hear me use that term I'm much
more comfortable with Black or African
Caribbean and so that is that is how I
would describe myself but I but I
understand it initially it came from a
good place it didn't come from a bad
place it came for a place of people
wanting to be inclusive and so that was
a term that they found that they were
able to use and feel comfortable with
and sometimes people go on a journey and
you know you have to move on that
journey but it isn't a term that I would
personally use and people get confused
you know because when you talk about
specific around black men being stopped
and searched for instance you know
they're ten times more likely it's very
different for black men than it is for
Muslim men even though the figures are
very similar so you know we do have to
break that down and contextualize it and
they're just picking up on something
that David said just in the modern
context now I am worried about I am
worried about the growth of violence we
have the largest growth of the far right
currently and what you're seeing now
is people sort of coalescing around you
know its historical figures that they
know nothing about that they feel that
something's being taken from them and
that is part of their recruitment
strategy and their recruitment tour to
say you are being emasculated or black
people are taking over or you know we're
no longer going to exist and so you know
I do think there is room there for that
or it's not even room there is a vital
component of us being honest about
history and stop deflecting and
distracting because what I'm finally
there's lots of deflection going on as
soon as you bring up especially in the
political sphere as soon as you bring it
bring it up all of a sudden there's a
deflection into something else and
you're like well no we have to we have
to do with this now otherwise we are not
going to dismantle any of the structural
or systemic racism that exists and it
means that the next generation will have
to deal with this again and I don't want
that to happen yeah let's come to you
David on that I mean taking Dawn's point
around the deflection and slavery seems
to be a forgotten part of British
history I mean the Brits tend to think
of it as an American story and what why
is that before I answer that can I just
say to Susan I I'm not suggesting
historians are rationally pessimistic
and philosophers aren't I actually blame
from our Sookie for making a pessimist
by exposing me to Thomas Hobbes at too
young an age so it's Plaza view that is
is the root cause that might have my
lifelong pessimism on the is he on the
issue of slavery and in 1807 Britain the
British Empire abolished the slave trade
in the 1830s slavery was abolished and
then in 38 instead people were released
and that was the sort of starting gun of
a moment of of moral self attribution
fallacy Britain used that moment and
it's not to say that both of those
things were not remarkable and it's not
to say that both of those things were in
some ways economically against British
entry
I don't fully buy the argument that
slavery had run its course by the 1830s
I think there's an argument for certain
parts of the Caribbean that was the case
but certainly not places like Guyana
Britain did do something remarkable in
the 1830s ending slavery but what
followed was this this sort of orgy of
self-satisfaction and Britain used the
abolition of slavery particularly to
look at America and feel better than
America but in that process was
forgotten that the enslaved people in
America from the 1840s and the sort of
boom in in cotton production that the
cotton was going to Liverpool and it was
then being distributed around the four
thousand Mills of Lancashire to produce
what was Britain's number one export in
the industrial revolution in some cases
in some arguably the key commodity than
just revolution which is cotton yarn and
cotton clothing the economists in the
1860s at the eve of the Civil War
estimated one in five people in Britain
was economically dependent to a certain
extent part of it from the cotton trade
or from the ancillary trades around it
now I was brought up in the northeast of
England and I was taught about the
history of revolution is my history and
it is it's the history of the white
working-class half of my family and I
was told every detail of the Industrial
Revolution and what probably what you
were told at school about spinning
jenny's and water frames and these great
men and Arkwright and the rest of them
nobody at any point in my entire
education totally where the cotton was
coming from told me that 1.8 million
African Americans half the African
Americans and slave and eve of the Civil
War that almost all of what they
produced went to Britain so if you look
at it very selectively and very
myopically if you edit out of your
knowledge and your vision certain
realities then you can look down in
America and you can conclude that
Britain is a superior is a superior a
morally superior nation if you forget
that Britain was importing sugar from
boot produced in Brazil until the 1880s
if you forget that Britain was involved
in forms of slavery in the Pacific and
Australia at the same time then if you
if you if you're willing to be that
myopic then you can decide button is a
modest
nation and as a result of doing that if
you ask someone to describe slavery this
might be less true now than it was say
10-15 years ago what they tend to
describe a fields of cotton of large
white houses at the end of avenues of
trees and a guy who looks like the sort
of Kentucky Fried Chicken blood that's
American slavery cotton slavery from the
high point of the cotton economy not
British not Jamaican proto industrial
sugar slavery the thing that built the
city Einstein was sitting in there and
that I mean that selective amnesia means
that one could argue the British lost
the Empire and kept the myth and but I
want to come to you Susan and can I just
also say there are over 1600 people in
the audience and over a hundred
questions already so we're gonna try to
get through as many as possible thank
you so much keep those questions coming
but Susan something I found really
interesting in your book is how you
write about Germans feeling a sense of
shame around their history particularly
their recent history in the 20th century
and the condemnation now of
anti-semitism is something that was you
described as Swift sharp and serious do
you think that that is required by
governments and societies in confronting
races histories so know when you may
have read my book more recently but I
have swift sharp and furious is not
arias sorry's not area but it's not it's
certainly not a way to describe say the
first 50 years after the end of the war
on the contrary they were very slow
about it they are not slow anymore they
are however much slower to condemn
racism in general I mean they're working
on it it's happening but they're kind of
allergic to anything that sounds
anti-semitic whereas they're still
working to you know extend that to
people of color there's no question
about that
um shame so the first generation that
kind of came of age
say the sixties and realized that their
parents and teachers if not Nazis you
know had done nothing to stop them with
very very few exceptions they were
ashamed of their parents they were
ashamed of the nation they tried to
pretend they were not for Danish if they
traveled in Europe I mean and there was
a there was a repulsion towards all of
German culture on in in that generation
it's it's an interesting I think there's
now a fairly healthy development we have
a very good president not another
Americans the Chancellor but our
president Steinmeier has been very good
about staying
most recently said you can only love
this country with a broken heart and you
know saying we absolutely cannot ever
fail to acknowledge the Nazi crimes but
we do need to look at points of light in
our history and I think that's something
that every nation needs to shame is
something that I I had a conversation
with one of my heroes Brian Stevenson I
don't know if he read his wonderful book
just mercy if you haven't you should
he's the founder of both the equal
justice initiative that gets people off
of death row and of the wonderful
national lynching memorial in Montgomery
Alabama which is worth a trip to
Montgomery Alabama I'm telling you but I
interviewed him because he said he was
very influenced is the only you know
American I knew who was saying this he
was influenced in his construction of
the memorial by what he had seen in
Germany particularly the stumbling
stones particularly the effort not just
to make gorgeous or inspiring memorials
in a particular place but to bring the
knowledge out into the streets to change
the landscape of the country so that
people will remember here a man was
lynched this house was built with slave
labor this middle of your doing
we talk about how shame is for real
change come to you on this Thank You
Susan because I mean is that is that
what the government needs to do what do
you think the government should do to
make amends is it simply apologizing is
it reparations is it changing the
landscape oh there's there's so much
that needs to be done that I mean in
regards to reparations don't forget we
received a tweet David will know the day
carry them out in 2015 that basically
said congratulations we've now finished
paying all of the slave owners you know
congratulations this is your fun Friday
fact or something which it was just
shocking it was 40 percent of you know
of the air of the country's budget went
to paying the slave owners so there's a
whole conversation to be had around
reparations but and then the first thing
there's loads of things but one of the
things has to be history I think we need
to be teaching history in its truest
forms in school from the very beginning
we need to set up an Emancipation Museum
it could be another name if you like I
mean I am not that I am not that fond of
having monuments and statues to be
honest I'd rather the money be spent on
on a museum and history and something
that's going to educate people I'd
rather the money be spent their most
practical things like looking like the
ethnicity pay gap what can we what can
be done about that this is how we start
breaking down the structural barriers
you know making sure the equality and
Human Rights Commission is independent
you know we have to tackle the
disproportionate amount of young black
and brown deep or in prison we have to
tackle the judicial system I was a
magistrate I can tell you you know how
it plays out in reality where you're
fighting to say that you know you have a
bias when you are judging this person
because you are judging them all to be
the same and not seeing the individual
case there is so much we have to do to
dismantle all the structural and
systemic racism I mean you mentioned
Stephen Lawrence earlier ask me that
was a clear case of where the structural
racism existed where because the
murderers were protected because they
were in a particular group and if it
wasn't for the fact that the Lawrences
had a clean record we may never have got
you know to the truth of that and
obviously a Labour government getting in
and and ordering the review but would
never have got to the truth of that and
so there's so much that needs to be done
and can be done and should be done and I
just want been most recently we
mentioned covert 19 we've got the public
health England report as to the whole
section of that report was removed the
government didn't exist we know they
exist we're thinking this is crazy you
know you cannot continue to do this and
so there's so much that can I needs to
be done one of the things actually in
the US that activists are pushing for is
this idea of defunding the police which
means divesting money from local police
budgets and reinvesting it into the
local communities mental health and
social service programs I mean does that
it does not have it equivalent here in
the UK no you have a crazy way of
funding your police force in America I
mean I'm just beginning to learn how
there has all been funded and how much
money the police force gets and I've
seen how much overtime they've been
getting as well doing during the rising
it's just absolutely crazy I mean
there's too much money's in the police
force and that needs to be renewed but
we don't really have that equivalence
here in the UK no David I'm gonna come
to you on the concept of Education and
you talk a lot about all you have talked
about the education system what does it
mean when people talk about the black
curriculum and what would that look like
here in here in the UK before I answer
that can I I'm very struck by something
that that Susan said those conversations
that happened at a national level but
also critically at a family level in
Germany when the generation who had been
children during the war those
confrontations they were I mean
there are some wonderful accounts of
them they were over the kitchen table
they were dramatic powerful
confrontations in which people sat down
with their parents and go what did you
do or what didn't you do I was talking
to a British public figure somebody
quite famous who I won't name and they
were describing this gulf between their
parents and their children this is
taking place over three generations that
their children could not and would not
spend time with or relate or talk to the
grandparents because the grandparents
had been involved at a very high level
in the British Empire and it reminded me
so much of the conversations that
Germany is a better place because they
took place between generations and to
understand this moment I think it really
is about generations look at the ages of
the people who took part in the
demonstration and the toppling of
Colston and krystal they were young now
compare that to the last mass
demonstration that we had in Britain
which were the brexit demonstrations now
I'm afraid that that was people of my
age that was my generation who feel
aggrieved by the loss of our place our
place in Europe now partly because this
is a generation this you have raised
matters more to younger people but also
partly because we're at home because
we're vulnerable and olds we've cleared
the space for young people to fight for
their issues and it is quite amazing how
old the demonstrations in Britain that
God's because of biggest a brexit youth
generational change is fundamental to to
this moment and the reason that young
people and I think this is black white
ground this is where the maybe the word
blaming is can be can be useful the
reason this is multi-generation is
because that generation despite what
they haven't been taught at school have
worked out that there are gaps in their
education they've worked out that
they've been told partial histories and
untruths and in some as my life as a
sort of art as a focus group where I
discover this because I'm on television
talking about these histories and I'm
stopped constantly by young people of
all races and there they're angry
about what they haven't been taught at
school they know that curriculum is
partial they watch programs like mine
they read books by a Carla and a for
Hirsch and many a do Lodge and they fill
in the gaps and that pissed off they
know they're there they're being lied to
and that's why they led the
demonstration and that's why something
very important happen in Bristol if this
was as the right-wing crest said
thuggery why is every shop in central
Bristol and I know those streets really
well why do they have their windows
still it today why was there no damage
to anything else
why did their target was a single bronze
statue in a city where they could have
there's a shock for the trainers 200
metres up the road why was it constant
because these kids are educated and
they're angry and they write to me don't
I see you not in quite a lot yeah
absolutely I mean I remember my parents
had Jamaican and I remember there was a
time when they stopped going to Jamaica
because it was too dangerous for them to
go to Jamaica and then I think I'm
having 18 or 19 and I decided to take
myself to Jamaica and you know and they
arrested for the whole time they were
worried and I had the most amazing time
and I came back angry because I said
you've allowed you've had a really
negative narrative to take over from
your memories of a really beautiful
country yes there's pockets but there's
pockets everywhere but to you know to
paint your makeup in such a negative
framework I was really angry and I you
know I thought going back to Jamaica
every year after that and so I think you
know once you learn something that's and
you've been told something else and you
learned that it's not exactly the whole
truth you are filled with all of this
emotion that just takes over and then
you overcompensate sometimes and I think
that's why you find you know lots of
young people on the streets campaigning
we're almost at time to turn to
questions but I'm gonna I'm gonna
address one last question Susan I'll
start with you for this you've said that
Britain is even further behind
educating itself than the US what do you
think a national reckoning in Britain
looks like so first of all I mean I
disagree with what both David and Dawn
have said I think Britons are even less
aware of although David's talking about
the next generation I do think there's a
breakthrough there but there's even a
less aware of the horrible parts of
their history than Americans are and
every it's said about the outsourcing of
slavery to the colonies is absolutely
white so in a way the British
colonialism Atticus double evil pushed
it it's bad for the blades they colonial
eyes it also allowed people to put
slavery as somebody else's problem and
of course as we know it was often much
more brutal in the Caribbean than even
was in the American South
so that's the first thing you know I you
asked dawn about a number of programs I
mean what one can learn from the German
experience is that there isn't one thing
that's going to do and all of these
things are pieces of public education
public memory I mean I unlike Donna I
understand things about appropriating
funds but I actually think changing the
shape the landscape of a city is
important and I think there ways to do
spending vast amounts of money on bronze
or all or whatever you know so but all
of those things taking reparations
seriously is a travesty I read that he's
doing better or in my book that you just
finished paying off the slaveholders no
one has discussed paying off the
enslaved people are their descendants
it's it's it blows the mind you know so
that needs to be an object of discussion
I know there's a discussion about black
history or black curriculum I am always
slightly nervous about Black Studies
programs and about women's studies
programs because I would
we ghettoization we have enough examples
of you know great writers of color great
women writers at you know and and piece
of history that's all history that needs
to be incorporated into a general
curriculum because it's not something
simply important for black people to to
know it's important for all of us to
consider our industry so yeah yeah I
think making perhaps the idea of black
history being part of the history of
literature not being you know taken off
into a black history month the way it is
in America or black stud for
post-colonial studies where a very small
number can can you know really pay
attention to that needs to be part of
the history that everyone learns so
David it sounded like there was optimism
there for you around the young people in
the next generation coming up I mean the
UK has Britain never has has not had a
civil rights movement in the same way
that the US has do you think that
Britain needs a civil rights movement
and is it the young people the next
generation that are going to take that
up or what does that look like I'm not
sure whether the American model of the
civil rights movement is the template we
should apply to British history and I
think we often we often do a strange
thing we compare ourselves to America
cuz we have a shared language when the
most pertinent the more pertinent
comparisons would be to compare compare
ourselves with France or with a
Netherlands who have a colonial history
much much more like era and I think it's
trying to cite the black experience in
Britain within the wider colonial
experience and this is where again you
know I understand the problems with with
the name the term bane but while their
specificity for the black experience
there's a shared colonial experience and
while the terms may be may be clumsy if
I talk to I have a friend who was
brought up in the northwest she's
Pakistani and like me he's literally
carries the scars of the 1980s on his
body like me he did loads of martial
arts which is something you'll find and
lots of black and Asian guys in my age
because there's quite reason why we were
playing doing martial arts while they
blame football because he was trying to
fight to stop being hospital honest and
he describes football the the the home
team playing in his town to me and it's
it's exactly one experience so we have
an enormous shared experience there but
beyond there we also have a deep shared
experience of the force that impact it
into our lives was the Empire now I'm
Nigerian so the world of the Atlantic
slave trade affected Nigeria I'm from a
town called UGA would day and and in
Oregon State and they're people from
that town who were recorded as being
enslaved and as people in the town who
were slave traders I have no idea what
my background is but what I do know is
that the story that it's wrapped up in
is the British Empire and that's the
same as someone from Sri Lanka it's the
same as someone from the Caribbean the
Imperial story the Imperial experience
is the big thing that all of us black
and white can agree on because that's
the discussion we haven't been having we
know nothing about the Empire and it is
hidden in plain sight it's in our
language it's in our cuisine it's in our
culture it's in our place names it's in
almost every aspect of our lives and we
don't even recognize it and it allows us
that this odd sort of form of
schizophrenia we boast that we are with
a nation that had the greatest empire
the world has ever seen on which the Sun
never said and yet we see ourselves as
this terribly fragile victim of people
who want to make us feel guilty and it
is this odd saber-rattling posturing
confidence and then this incredible
vulnerability whenever this is the
subject is is is raised the urge is
Dawne set to deflect it that's a that is
a sort of it's almost like a sort of a
bipolar attitude towards our history
thank you David I so we have over 200
questions so I'm gonna jump right into
questions and but first let me thank you
all for we got through so much there and
Don I'm gonna
first question to you and it's from
Corinne who says with the Conservatives
in power there doesn't seem to be room
for a real conversation about racism and
how it permeates our society when MPs
are literally denying racism and the
policy in decision-making rests with
those in power how can we hope for
lasting change I'm not gonna lie it is
really really hard because those people
that are currently in position of power
where they could do something about it
first of all you know we do have to get
over that hurdle of them acknowledging
that the problem exists without saying
but when they do acknowledge the problem
exists they say we'll have a
consultation or we'll get a
public-health
image report but we work under you all
the report will hide the bits that
actually make the difference dismantle
some of the structure and systemic
racism that exists so what we have to do
and can do is to highlight it is to
highlight it and break them down we
literally have to break them down and it
is hard you know when they when they put
up and and and also I sometimes you know
when I'm feeling quite generous I will
think about the journey that some of
their MPs have gone through you know
they're black MP knees or they're Asian
MPs just to survive in that space that
they're in so they've had to do in I or
the strategy just to survive in their
space so you've got all of all of that
that you have to do it before we can
either even get to the legislation but
there's so much to do and I think what
we're going to do next week Thursday I
have a debate on the floor in the house
and how Cove it affects the B AME
communities and so we're going to start
breaking down all of the stuff that this
government is trying to hide and I think
where people see the truth we don't even
have to see it you feel it because we're
all living in the moment that we will
slowly get that change but it is very
difficult and very frustrating
Thanks honest honest answer and I'm
going to direct one question to you
David and one question to you Susan just
so that we can get through these and so
there's been a couple of questions
around statues and the broad the broad
because where do we draw the line do we
go through the lives of every historical
figure with as the questioner asks 20
the lens of 21st century racism criteria
and why just racism as opposed to gender
discrimination and other types of
bigotry and also somebody asking from a
journalist from the Liverpool Echo
saying is there any place monuments
statues in particular in Liverpool that
should be removed or renamed and in
Susan a question for you um from Martin
can I genuinely be ashamed of something
I have not done so yes I could be
ashamed if racist thoughts but can I be
ashamed on behalf of others who died
centuries before I was born
on the issue of status I don't think
race is the only criteria today we've
seen a call to parents tattoo of
baden-powell for the reason that he
supported he was favorable towards the
Nazis and he called mine camp for
wonderful book I don't think this is
entirely about race and also if it were
about race then that wouldn't it
wouldn't be the case that the roads must
full movement started in South Africa
with Africana students at the University
of Cape Town who remembered roads as an
oppressor of the Africana member the
Jameson wrote the Jameson raid so this
is not just about race lots of people
black and white can have a problem with
a figure like Cecil Rhodes because
they've read what he actually did also
and these what is wrong with the idea of
looking at who these people on pedestals
are why is that such a strange idea that
we want to know whether they are worthy
of valoración because statues not a
mechanism for telling us history they
are way of validating people and we is
it that's unusual and ideas they're that
challenging idea that weeds we'd look to
see whether these people are worthy of
validation and one of the most powerful
myths in all of this is that people that
this idea of the 21st century lens in
his lifetime Sessler Rhodes was a deeply
controversial figure a profoundly
disliked figure by millions of people
he was so disliked that the three
founders of
today Botswana with their friends in a
missionary society worked out that they
could keep their land out of Cecil
Rhodes as private empire by gumming to
Britain and appealing directly to the
British population because they hope to
test the road so much so three black
guys who come to 1890s Britain go on a
press tour and win favor over and and be
favored by the government eventually
over Cecil Rhodes he was hated at the
time there's this at this idea that
these people were entirely popular in
their lifetime and only now as live
liberal lefties hate them think about
these people most of them are
politicians now and then and all times
people didn't like their politicians in
the past always loved politicians always
loved the generals always loved the
ruling elite always loved the lords and
the Dukes and the Vikings on top of and
on top of the pedestals
read some British history they were
hated at the time I'm just gonna press
you just on on the UM the point around
Liverpool because a journalist from the
Liverpool Echo is asking you know
there's there's an ongoing debate about
the origins of Penny Lane and whether
it's connected to the slave trade and
Julia was wondering whether this came up
in your research I did nice to live in
them when I went to loop university I
think the much more pertinent case is
the Gladstone's the gas streams are
absolutely fundamental to the story of
Liverpool and the Glassons are the
family John Gladstone the father of
William Ewart Gladstone the Prime
Minister the Gladstone's received more
compensation at the end of slavery than
any single dynasty and after after
slavery they were fundamental they were
key to inventing the Indian indentured
labour system which was the system of
labour that was used to replace slavery
so I think we need to think a lot about
the Gladstone family and their role in
mr. in the story of Liverpool but I have
to say Liverpool a city I love very much
city I lived in for 3 years and a city
with a slavery museum sitting in Bristol
the city I love very much lived in for
22 years I'd yet to notice the slavery
museum instead we've had a statue of a
slave trader on a pedestal 125 years so
a little tongue comparatively well but
they're still a long way to go I think
Glasgow has got a long way to go I think
London
in the fact that were only now having a
public conversation about the West India
Docks the reason we're having that
conversation is because they've been
camouflaged behind this phrase Canary
Wharf it's the West India Docks it was
the biggest private construction in
British history when it was built it was
so expensive and Act of Parliament had
to be pushed through and what it was was
the biggest facility in Europe for the
reception from the ships of the Atlantic
trade of sugar a slave produced
commodity that was a fundamental part of
the infrastructure that relied on the
bodies of 800,000 people thanks David
I'm gonna come you Susan yes yeah I
liked all the people who say you know
are we going to judge them by the
standards of today I mean first of all
David Whitely points out a lot of them
while highly controversial including
Winston Churchill in his day but but
secondly what's wrong with the idea of
progress I mean we actually plan with
the paints of moral progress you know
and questions about racism slavery
question of women you know it's it's
it's not return to you but I think it
you know it ought to be acknowledged the
second thing is there are other things
to do with statutes
besides throw them in the harbor there's
context is ation mooring is the
interesting way to go about things and
it needs to be done as a process of
democratic debate which itself will
bring the history so here's something
like almost every American and and I
come from a family my mother was
involved in the civil rights movement in
the south of the 60s I had no idea when
those Confederates taxes were put up and
what purpose they served in for about
five years ago when the debate over them
began and it turned out it wasn't about
my heritage and my father it was a very
conscious part of the rewriting of
history or the falsifying of history on
the part of certain groups and it took
returning the urge to do this
every time the civil rights movement
made in Cain he would suddenly get new
statutes coming up okay so an educated
person learned a lot of history in the
last five years over these debates and
I'm sure that happen in in Britain as
well what he might have to think about
doing with Winston Churchill is the sort
of thing that is now happening in the US
over Thomas Jefferson at least and
equally beloved figure in American
history you know he wrote the words we
hold these truths to be self-evident all
men are created equal and he not only
owned slaves he fathered slaves who he
did not free in his probably mean it's
quite crazy and he didn't say to give
him credit towards the end of his life I
tremble for my country when I think that
God is just because he thought that
America would pay for slavery so what
they've done now for example at
Monticello which is the home he built
it's gorgeous
they've also have archaeologists
unearthed English slave quarters and you
can take two different tours and
hopefully most people take both of them
one from the perspective of Thomas
Jefferson and the other from the
perspective of the enslaved people and
one needs to think about creative ways
to do that I'm gonna come to you John
and Susan I might come back to you on
the point of being ashamed for something
um historically but somebody's doing a
question around how you feel as an MP
walking around Parliament and the
artwork and imagery that is displayed in
the palace part of the estate in
particular and whether you think there's
room to move some of the artwork to a
museum make room for more art that is
representative of the diversity of you
know Parliament or Britain and I'm also
gonna add another another question a few
folks have asked should people from the
black and Asian American communities be
looking to enter the justice system and
so on as a way to make change is that is
that I mean you yourself said that you
worked in our state is that something
that you think people should be
considering so I take the easy one first
and
yes I think people should absolutely
consider being part of the justice
system
people should apply to be a magistrate
they shouldn't give up if they say no
because they said no to me the first
time I applied and and made sure that I
reapplied because that is vital because
until we get people in different
positions in society we are not going to
get the change that we see our change
will be small
they'll be incremental but they'll be
small and tiny so it's vital I I've I
stopped people go into prison just
because I brought a different
perspective to the debating room so our
hundred percent people should should
apply should be part of them school
governors we see a higher exclusion of
black kids in schools and we know about
the you know the school-to-prison the
exclusion to Prison Pipeline so we'll
need people to be more active socially
in regards to Parliament how do I feel
so memory first of all say that there
there is a commission in Parliament
where they looking at different patents
and different works of art and we
recently saw Bernie grant a lovely
picture of Bernie grant was hung in
Parliament in portcullis house so
there's different bits of art being
commissioned how do I feel I know we
haven't got that much time but when I
first entered Parliament in 2005 there
used to be a picture of Enoch power
outside of my office so every Tyrell -
into my office every day I would see
Enoch Powell so every time every morning
I walked into my office I would give him
the finger salute and you know and I
would go into into my office and then I
thought I don't actually want to start
my day every day doing that I want to
start my day of a different mindset and
so I asked for it to be removed and they
were partying and then you know a couple
of months later and I said look it's
really fine if you don't remove the
picture I will so it's your choice and
then it was removed that's how I feel
about do it ourselves isn't it
I'm gonna come to you David and there's
been a couple of questions around this
which is folks is Jones saying that
statues should go into museums but
somebody asking and I'll see if I can
find the question how can we trust the
museums when they themselves are
systemically racist so Jennifer asks how
do you trust the museum to tell the
story of costume and somebody else was
asking you know isn't part of the
problem that the museums themselves
looted and this is a time for examples
like the British Museum to give back
some of the things like the Elgin
marbles or the minion bronzes I think
that's exactly the reason why these
statues will be great in museums because
it would reunite the looters with red
stolen goods
I mean moment to more questions and
maybe ask you again to respond to this
know might come to Susan as well the
question is is acceptance and
understanding of white privilege by
white people essential for us to move
forward and this comes from Philip
Bushell Marshall I might start with you
yeah yes but it all depends on exactly
what one doesn't wish and about it you
know and I guess this goes back to the
same question mice that one can feel
shame for a nation in which one has has
benefited from privilege for accidental
facts about one's birth okay so if that
is a goat towards you know actually
changing things I think that's okay so
recognizing
white privilege to me means number one
recognizing you know that there's stuff
that I got that I didn't learn um I hope
it's awful when somebody said maybe it
was Donald how can we use their white
privilege by going out on the streets
and and throwing the statues in so that
they won't get there's much less likely
- can you arrest it actually my daughter
is organizing exactly something like
this and closing for the moment well I
just think it means being abject I don't
think it means you know tearing one's
hair out I think it is fighting for
universal justice using that privilege
in ways that it can be can be useful to
a fight but again I'm I'm always wary of
our tendency in this day and age on the
left to see things in terms of tribes
I'm you know again it's about truth and
not merchants versus my truth it's about
the history and Susan and one of the
other questions actually speaking about
the truth comes from Lucy and says and
I'm gonna give this to you Don in the
light of the news that slave owners were
hugely compensated over generations
should the descendants of the enslaved
be exempt from paying taxes or fast
paying for education are there other
creative ways of addressing reparations
I like the idea of not having to pay
taxes but I mean I agree with Susan on
the white privilege point as well I
think that was spot on
but I think there's things that needs to
be done right there's a apprenticeships
that need to be done I I mean I I didn't
I ended at the talk in the Bank of
England and they've got this big
apprenticeship scheme and I said what
actually doesn't even matter how much
you give it's never going to be enough
because you were built on the backs of
slaves so you owe a lot more than
you ever going to get so and I think
that's what history will do you see
history will highlight the debt owed and
I think that's really important because
people often say you know why why do you
want this or why don't that I mean I
don't personally want any money I don't
want a pot of money for my own
reparations but I want to ensure that we
have some equity in society and we're
going to get equity in societies given
some people a bit more and that is how
it needs to work it's really easy to be
successful when you don't when you
didn't have to pay for labor you know
it's really easy to say we built this
well you built that on the backs of
enslaved labor actually that's not
something to be proud of so the debate
and the discussion needs to be had in
those terms I'm afraid I can't endorse
no pain of no taxes that's very I may
have pushed that a little far I'm gonna
come to you on the question of from Shem
Issa do you think the telling of true
African history is important as a means
of decolonizing history education and
essentially saying not having history
African history start from a place of
slavery and colonization but the many
kingdoms and civilizations before
European settlement I think that's
that's important and you know I think
history matters to people of African
descent in this very specific way
because Africa the father didn't have a
history the British went to India they
told the Indians that they were backward
and they're an uncivilized but they
didn't say they didn't have a history
because it was manifest and obvious and
in their face but they did say that to
Africans so I think it's really
important but I think there's something
to me and I probably would say this
because my interest is imperialism
there's also about this is half a
millennia of contact between Africa and
Europe and it didn't begin with slavery
it began with gold began with the big
commodity because it was European
contact the desire to get round Africa
to get to the gold was about cutting out
the middlemen of the Arab traders who
carried it across across the
Mediterranean it was about gold it began
about gold also began about ivory read
about the
British expedition of the English
expeditions I should say in the 1540s
and 1550s Tudor expedition to Africa
it's not about slavery they bring
Africans to Britain but they bring them
to teach them English to send them back
as translators so they can help them get
more gold we if we see it just as
slavery then that's a problem but I
think there's one other thing is and I
understand what people say this and I
said I I'm cautious saying this because
I'm Nigerian and not African American or
Caribbean but when people say they feel
ashamed when their ancestors to describe
the slaves what I say to them is read
about the lives of slaves they were
remarkable people they survived a system
designed to crush them and kill them and
dehumanize them and commoditize them and
they came out of that roti survived
those who escaped people like Frederick
Douglas with their humanity intact with
their humanity on display and vivid and
powerfully articulated the idea I think
it's a real danger of seeing the word
slave as is a dehumanizing term even now
because they were some of the strongest
people who've ever lived
[Music]
we did have like an Emancipation Museum
I within a slavery museum because you
know there were there so much as you say
strength that we don't talk about and so
that's why I think we should focus on
those kinds of words it's the worry I
have though is all we focus on is
abolition we always focus on the last
chapter of the story and I mean the big
thing for me is we haven't got an empire
museum it's the bigger story with each
entry how this little island of the
coast of Europe took over a third of the
world's land surface that's the biggest
story in British history and we have
museums too you know almost every
element of our history but we haven't
got a history - the biggest museum - the
biggest the biggest question the biggest
mystery the biggest phenomenon in
British history
I assume that they don't want to have
right around this sorry I'll come back -
Farah Chaudhary asks does this selective
amnesia of British colonialism come from
the shame of the decolonization of the
British Empire so maybe to your point
David is the fact that there isn't an
my museum part of the shame of having
lost the Empire there was when the
Empire was not something that was hidden
away when it was when it was active I
mean the history of the Empire is of
grandeur burs of Jubilees of of the
Empire being sort of you know proudly
celebrated the famous map on every every
classroom but the British should have
been sort of slightly disconnected story
with the Empire because even when the
Empire was active I don't think people
fully understood and there's lots of
reasons to believe this fully understood
how much it changed their lives
sugar was just in the shops the fact
that something had been a luxury in the
16th century and became one of the key
sources of calories by the 19th century
was something that people sort of forgot
this infrastructure behind it tea was a
birthright this incredible story of
industrial espionage of taking this
drink from China transplanting it to
India getting a million Indians to
produce it but we're sort of all hidden
behind just this drink that became you
know what's more British than a cup of
tea think about the names we have 40 in
English breakfast tea builders tea Earl
Grey all of that tea is Chinese most of
it was from India the most popular well
one of the most popular brands in tea in
this country is called Yorkshire tea
they're not growing tea in Yorkshire
yeah while it was happening it was
hidden in plain sight it impacted
everyone's life every day
everybody consumed so I mean it was an
imperial products and yet you could
somehow live this this jewel split
mentality well you didn't think much
about the empire but it shaped your life
last word I'm really sorry this I can
have this conversation for hours so
thank you all so much I'm going to give
a last word to you both Susan and Dawn
Susan what I mean your tea
you've written about the guilt in the
shame and the Germans have had to work
through any last thoughts on that so
there's a question there was a question
I'm often asked in fact I was asked when
I
last fall in London and the popular
television shows we don't have anything
to learn from the Germans
Hitler was about world domination and
fortunately I would quick on my feet
enough to say I never set on the British
Empire you know what are you talking
about this is a very new thought to both
the presenters who were interviewing me
and you know you often get the claim
Nazi crimes were worse than any other
crimes in the world and therefore
nothing can be compared to them it's
somehow offensive to do that I do not
think it is trivialize it those who died
in the Holocaust to remember first of
all that 14 million Slavic people were
also brutally civilians brutally on the
Western Front that you know many many
people in other places have been
tortured and murdered and I mean the
entire point of remembering the
Holocaust is not to say well never again
should German put Germans put Jews in
concentration camps but let us learn and
let us universalize the principle that
no form of evil of this kind and the
differences their similarities we do not
want to be party to any of these and
Thank You Susan don't last words are you
optimistic for the future I think we
have to be other ways of what's the
point but I think the fact that we've
seen the younger generation come out and
the fact that they are so inclusive and
ready and hungry the change to make
society better and then you've got the
next generation and the next generation
look at the people that being arrested
for
or the environment you know there are
the grandparents who kids have got them
out on the street so they can afford to
now get kind of a criminal record so the
fact that you've got generations now
activism coming together hopefully I am
optimistic that we will see change
together but it needs to be a systemic
and lasting so it means that we
dismantle the structures on the way we
learn about issue and the way we we've
moved to get other either with a common
understanding of what we need to not go
back to and repeat history so yes I'm
optimistic
here's to systemic and lasting change
thank you David as yoga
Susan Eamonn don't Butler I'm gonna pass
back too far thank you so much pleasure
thank you thank you to our whole panel
and thank you Yasmin for being such a
brilliant chair for this evenings event
if you'd like to purchase David's book
black and British a photographer got in
history or Susan's book learning from
the Germans confronting race and the
memory of evil you can see them on the
book tab on the right hand side of your
screen and just click through to
waterstones please do sign up to our
mailing list on our website intelligence
squared comm that's where you'll find
out about all of our upcoming events we
can send you emails let you know what's
coming up and do consider becoming a
member of the intelligent square plus
community with the special discount
codes that I mentioned earlier monthly
or annual depending on which one you'd
like to subscribe to you you'll get 20%
off and the first month free if you
register by next Friday we look forward
to seeing you at another event very soon
and once again I'm delighted to say we
had over 1700 people in the audience
tonight so thank you for joining us from
all of us at intelligence squared
you